what's going on guys bang bang in the
month of January Bitcoin was up over 40
percent this is one of the hottest stars
to a year since 2013. many of you may be
asking why is Bitcoin rallying so hard
especially when inflation is still
sticky and high and the Federal Reserve
remains committed to draining liquidity
out of the market well I'm gonna give
you a quick crash course in central
bank's ability to pump liquidity in and
take it out of Market if we look over
the last 60 days the top 10 central
banks around the world have increased
their balance sheet size by 653 billion
dollars combined that is a massive
amount of liquidity that's getting
pumped into the system now it's
interesting because the Federal Reserve
has drained about 150 billion dollars of
liquidity and the ECB has drained about
430 billion dollars of liquidity at the
same exact time the Federal Reserve and
the ECB are taking liquidity out of the
market but still there's been a net gain
of 653 billion dollars over the last 60
days around the world
this is coming mainly because China has
pumped about 500 billion dollars of
liquidity into the market anytime that
you see the top 10 central banks adding
tons of liquidity to the market like
this you can bet that stocks Bitcoin and
other types of assets are rallying hard
yes the Federal Reserve remains
committed they continue to hike interest
rates as they did this week but
ultimately they are being diluted by so
much liquidity entering the market from
other central banks as we see Bitcoin
going up 40 percent to start the year
I'd like to argue that it has something
to do with risk on risk off or maybe
that it has something to do with the
debt limit and there probably is some
truth to that story but really when you
look at the top 10 central banks around
the world increasing their balance sheet
size by 653 billion dollars in a 60-day
period of course that money's got to go
somewhere and Bitcoin has been a big
winner and a big recipient of all that
cash now what do we need to pay
attention to over the next couple of
weeks is will that liquidity surge
continue or have the central banks put
so much liquidity hundreds of billions
of dollars into the market and they're
going to run out if you listen to
someone like Gordon Johnson on Twitter
he thinks that all of that liquidity has
pretty much been used up and now China
and other central banks are going to
cool off for a little bit your guess is
as good as mine but what I do know is
that central banks they're basically
like the Geppetto of financial markets
they simply sit there as puppeteers
pulling the strings of different asset
prices and making markets dance they do
this by adding liquidity or taking it
away so continue to watch what is the
balance sheet change for the top 10
central banks if you see those numbers
going positive and lots of liquidity
entering the market you can pretty much
bet that Bitcoin will be a beneficiary
of that but if you see them draining
liquidity and the Federal Reserve ECB
and other central banks winning out and
doing what they're intending to do well
that's what happened last year almost
two trillion dollars was drained from
the market and we saw all asset prices
across the board crash the central banks
are in control the old adage don't fight
the FED is as true as ever and Bitcoin
is hanging in the balance so keep
watching those central bank balance
sheets and I'll see you guys next week